the last piece that clicked was okay
there's something big here
i love this industry there's an ability
to really make a difference for small
businesses
and then it was like you know what this
needs to be you doing it it can't be
somebody else
executing on your vision you need to do
[Music]
it
hey i livesheets thank you for joining
me all the way from california how are
you
i'm great thanks for having me michael
of course i'm i'm both jealous and not
jealous of you i can't wait to come back
and
and and live in silicon valley it's such
a it's a wonderful place but
i you know it's an interesting time
where we are now so i'll hopefully we'll
get to meet in person in a few months
but for now
i'll get to hear all about your journey
all the way from uh from
israel and chicago booth to greylock
uh mckinsey and now blue vine
first walk me back all the way to your
pizza delivery days
what is that all about
um i think uh well i started my
my first job was delivering pizzas okay
and i think this is
uh highlighting the fact that um um
you know i didn't start my career in
tech and and even even
further more um you know kind of a funny
or an anecdote here i did not own a
computer before i was around 22.
really um so yes i i was a carefree
teenager
surfed uh didn't really care about
technology
um in the military i served in infantry
i i did not go to 80 to 100 or 81 100.
um i i basically um decided to go
and pursue a technology
career back in um it was 2000
when i um started my degree in
electrical engineering
and um it was due to a choice that i
really didn't know what i wanted to do
in life at the time and
high tech seemed like a good opportunity
you know tech was booming in the year
2000 um
didn't have a lot of sense of what that
means but you know what you know people
are making good money in technology
why don't i go into high tech and the
pizza delivery story connects to that
uh i think a little bit even comically i
used to deliver pizzas
um i lived in hamata vive at the time
and i delivered pizzas
um in a pizzeria in amateur
and i used to deliver a lot to the town
like the tech companies and
other places and i asked him like what
are you guys doing and they were like
well we're engineers
um i was like okay i need to go and do
this job
this is a good job you know getting the
pizza delivered to you versus delivering
so that was the start of my you know but
my pizza delivery
days kind of like grounded me into tech
i love that what was it pizza fino by
any chance
it was pizza it is my all-time favorite
pizza i'm from ramatavee as well and i
used to eat there almost on a daily
basis so
so we already have a huge thing coming
in and i'm hugely appreciative even more
than what you do at blue vine
i think what you did with pizza fino it
tops that much more uh
so so thank you for that but but you
actually your entrepreneurial experience
goes
beyond just just the pizzas and where
you're and then you're understanding to
transition to a different industry
your family your you say you're a third
generation
entrepreneur right so talk to me a
little bit about about that and how that
runs in the family
um it's an interesting uh story here and
i and i don't know if it runs in the
family
and and i'll explain further on that uh
my dad
was a small business owner he had a
physical therapy clinic in
the upper east side of new york for or
30 years
his dad owned a um kind of lighting
electricity lighting stored in in
dieselgo for 40 years
so both of them were small business
owners and you know the reason why small
business owners start their business is
many of them don't want a boss
right they want to be able to run you
know their own kind of thing and do
their own uh you know
run their own show and so i i view small
business owners as entrepreneurs
by their own right yeah um you know they
start their company their or their
business or their you know whatever
um and they share many of the same
things that we do
in in startup land when we start a
company there's many of the same pain
points you need to figure out
your business plan your hiring how to
generate revenue
of course it's it's a different outcome
they're not looking to build
a billion dollar companies but there's a
lot of the same stuff especially when
they start out
right um you know in terms of running in
the family i don't know if it runs in
the family
i i didn't know that i wanted to be an
entrepreneur
up until i started blue vine if you look
at my career you know it
it's pretty it's a pretty safe journey i
kind of stuck to
larger companies pretty strong brand
names i didn't really take any risk
before i started blue vine there are
some people that
you know they graduate from from college
and they know that their destiny is to
start a company
you didn't have no they want to be an
entrepreneur i did not have that
interesting i was i very much followed a
safe path
and the reason i started blue vine was
less so about
the personal um you know
interest or the draw to actually become
a founder
but rather the opportunity and the
calling you know i
you know even further adding to that in
the beginning the mindset
working in venture capital and seeing
the opportunity to start blueprint i was
like
why don't we find a ceo to do this well
when we found somebody else to do right
i wasn't even thinking that this would
be me but i got so consumed with the
idea
and the opportunity that at some point
you know this is mine i need to really
go do this
so walk me through that thinking process
because your principal at greylock one
of the best investment groups in the
world
uh based in that you were in the in the
cohort based in israel
you're thinking about this industry
you're thinking about small business
owners obviously this has a connection
to you coming from a family of small
business owners and you're understanding
that there's a gap in the market
an opportunity that at the end you
decide to go and fulfill it yourself
with blue vine
what are those weeks days months like
what does that process
look like for a safe journeyed you know
technology guy and and somebody who's
working in tech
working in a fantastic branding mckenzie
greylock and you're saying you know what
i'm ready to go start my own journey
what is that thinking process like for
you it was an evolution
uh so first when when you work in
venture you get exposed to
entrepreneurship in general you work
with a lot of founders you assess
investments
and um you know entrepreneurship is
somewhat infectious
you know you see the excitement of
people starting something from nothing
um you kind of follow their journey from
the outside in
and um you know there's a lot of
excitement that rubs off so
first you know being inventor did
move me closer in that direction the
story of blue line at the beginning was
was more of an analytical exercise
i had an opportunity to look and and see
a lot of companies in the fintech space
through uh you know rear locked israel
and um
there were heavy investors in fintech at
the time and i realized that there's an
opportunity there's a white space
um specifically at the time where we we
started the company in factoring
and i was a big fan of what was
happening in online financing and i
realized
there were still areas of opportunities
and so when i when i learned about
factoring at the time
um it clicked that there is an ability
to take a page from
what was being done in other another
sort of
product and applied here and the market
size is quite large and so that
from an analytical from the outside in
it really connected
and then there was a personal passion
always to
um evaluate and see opportunities within
small businesses and this does relate to
my personal background i did grow up
around my father's business i i heard
about him talking about
growing up about with his father's
business around his father's business
it's something that was always
around me i had a connection to this
segment
and so those two things came together in
terms of uh wow there is really
something here
and the last piece that clicked was
okay there's something big here i love
this industry there's an ability to
really make a difference for small
businesses
and then it was like you know what this
needs to be you doing it
it can't be somebody else executing on
your vision you need to do it
and um you know while i was 35 at the
time
i did not want to be an entrepreneur
until that point in my life
at that point you know sort of like the
regret minimization
framework kicked in it was like if i
don't do this i'm going to regret it
you know 20 years in the future so um i
jumped in
so do you categorize yourself as a
full-time entrepreneur
um i categorize myself as a full-time
founder yes a full-time entrepreneur i
you know i i think when you start a
company the definition of entrepreneur
versus ceo
um they get kind of mixed over the life
of a company
i i think i'm becoming more and more of
a ceo as time grows
goes by and the company becomes larger
of course
i'm a founder ceo so that is something
that is always
part of my um sort of outlook but uh
but you know as time goes by as you take
more of the role of the ceo and your
role in the company rather than just
being
the founder sure can you share a little
bit more about about the industry and
the market of small business small
businesses what's happening today
especially in the united states that
you're observing what what is how do you
even get to that that big pain point
that you've observed
and what is the sort of the what is the
trend look like as we are now in 2021 i
guess
so i will say that the vision of the
company evolved significantly from when
we started we started with a very
narrow uh you know product set answering
factoring and making that an online
product then evolved to providing a full
range of credit products and today
we're really involved in in delivering
intent banking and so it wasn't
right it wasn't any pivot along with the
way this was a continued expansion of
the business model and the strategy
you're considering it as an involvement
as an involvement of that narrow idea
that you've understood okay there's
actually a bigger gap than what we
thought
yes yes um you know there was an entry
point here but over time realizing that
the real opportunity is to essentially
fix small business banking as
a whole and factoring is part of credit
and credit is part of banking
and banking as a whole is broken for
small businesses and that is the true
opportunity that we're looking to solve
which includes everything that belongs
under making checking accounts
credit payments everything else um this
has been
uh sort of an evolution that happened
through understanding our customers and
their pain points
now when you are referring to small
businesses um
broadly what has been happening in the
last you know two decades
essentially they've been outsourcing
their financial services from their bank
no longer did they do most of their or
interact with their bank for most of
their financial
services need they still hold their
checking account with their bank but
payment processing they get from square
from paypal from strive
payments they get from bill.com credit
they get you know historically from
third party lenders like us and others
it's been a world where things that you
would expect to get from your bank
and corporations definitely get from
their bank small businesses
end up needing to rely on many
third-party
providers not their bank and that is not
an ideal market that's not an ideal
outcome the ideal outcome is they can
actually have
a banking partner that can answer all
their needs under one place and
everything works together seamlessly
and that is what we're doing providing
them access to everything they need
under one roof
and making it very easy to transact
digitally
that's another big point that really
connects to the pandemic
um it's interesting most consumers
don't go to the branch anymore i don't
know when's the last time you went to
blind branch i
sometimes ask that question and some
people tell you no i actually went last
week
yeah i don't even know that there are
branches that are still existing you're
you're telling me new news now
i can't believe that they're still
operating in person they are and
um and you know when you when you look
at the small business segment
interestingly while consumers over time
have stopped going to the branches
definitely the younger generations
small businesses small business owners
on average still go
um on average at least once a week to
the branch
why because they don't have everything
at their disposal to be able to transact
digitally
you know adding to that the pandemic um
that doesn't work anymore so certainly
there's a lot of like
tailwinds right now for providers like
us to be able to provide
a small business the ability to transact
digitally
you know without needing to go to a
branch certainly right now is is not a
time where small businesses value going
to the branch and
you know even before it was a hassle and
a time suck now it's just
impossible and there's a health con
concern uh so that's certainly giving us
an increased increased push for what
we're doing
in addition um during this time when
small businesses have been
struggling and facing a lot of
challenges uh given the
you know the economic environment um you
know
the banking industry has not necessarily
all stepped up to serving them um
you know in in a very robust way and so
the fact that we are 100
focused on this segment and they're able
to deliver really um
you know great banking experience i
think today even speaks
even more volume no and i think that one
of the most fascinating things
that i love about what you're doing is
that you know it's not just that you're
that you're coming in and you're
educating the market but you have a
series of other players that are coming
and they're educating the market from
the different angles right so obviously
the digital transactions and the whole
the whole way that we're that we're
dealing with with
digital assets today are are completely
are completely different than 10 15
years ago and and having that end-to-end
banking solutions i'm looking at the
different banks here in israel
and in the united states the adaptation
is so slow they're still focused on
their
on the different consuming habits and i
think that what you're doing here is is
it has impeccable timing and obviously i
can't imagine in in the
pandemic of 2020 the different you know
the the way that you're seeing your
vision coming together and how the world
has accelerated towards this new world
that you're providing a solution to
but hey i also want to pick your brain
as the founder and ceo so you're saying
that you're
tr that you're transitioning solely from
you know being like the founder and the
entrepreneur towards now being the ceo
you're the ceo of a of a multi uh
company that raised hundreds of millions
of dollars right it's a big
responsibility
lots of employees uh now you really are
you know a big
the ceo of what considerably big company
what are some of the
thought shifts that you've had to do as
a leader
intrinsically as you're transitioning to
role because your role today i am
imagining is
very very different from your role four
or five years ago right and it's been a
very quick shift
i mean quick is a relative term right
it's been uh
seven years since we started the company
and it feels like it's like startup
years are like dollar years you know
on one hand it feels you know it was
just only yesterday we started the
company but when i'm reflecting back and
everything that we went through over
over seven years it's a lot you know it
feels like a lifetime right
now yes the transition is significant
from
you know starting out over time growing
it doesn't happen in one day
in the beginning right founder you do
everything that you need to do
you're basically the you know the cook
the
you know the office manager the you know
recruiter
the programmer you do whatever you need
to do in the beginning you roll up the
sleeves and you
work towards getting stuff done and um
you know
in the beginning there's a lot of focus
on you doing um
you know of course um you know you hire
employees but
you you are involved in whatever needs
to be done and
there's a lot of you know there's a lot
of things to be done and shortage of
resources
and you make all the decisions in the
beginning a lot of the decisions flow
through you
over time it becomes less of doing
but more of making sure that you have
the right people in place and you're
empowering them and you're creating the
right organizational structures
to be able to scale so it's interesting
um you know the type of work that you do
as a as a founder really changes every
two years based on the size of the
company and based on the
um and based on kind of the um
general scale of the business so you
know it's not one day but it does
every two years you kind of need to
think about what what do i need to be
doing what do i not need to be doing the
things that you always own as the as a
ceo is
vision you always are responsible for
selling the company
selling i mean to investors to employees
um
you know to media you're always on a
sales mode
you always drive culture that happens
from the early days even when the
company is larger that is the
responsibility of the ceo
and um you know and again vision right
like vision and strategy is sort of
connected
and there are different types of ceos
they're they're you know sort of like
more product
oriented ceos and there's more sales
oriented ceos
i personally um i put myself more in the
first category and so i'm very
passionate about product
and i do get involved in product even my
level of
involvement with product has changed
considerably over time in the beginning
i was literally
writing specs myself and working with
the engineers over time
you know as we grew had product manager
now we have a phenomenal chief product
officer
now it's more about just providing
feedback around the roadmap making sure
that
you know um the vision is instilled with
with the
you know the plan that we're putting
together and then obviously
i have opinions around certain you know
certain product comments specifically
around product
experience that i make sure to voice
them but i am no longer in the driver's
seat i'm more of a
of a coach of a you know a reactive sort
of position
you need to be you know when you're
building a company the main thing you
want to do is make sure you have really
great people that are motivated and are
pushing forward
because as you scale you can't be
everywhere so yeah it becomes from
you doing everything to make sure that
you have phenomenal people that are able
to execute on your vision
so it sounds to me like your journey is
full of firsts right every two years
some
every two years your role is changing
but that means that really every two
years you're reinventing your role as
the ceo you have to adapt to
to the new environment every time you
get a chance to debrief over what you've
learned and you sort of the skills
you've mastered you all of a sudden have
to reinvent and master these new skills
so how do you keep yourself in check
because it sounds to me like a lot of
the things that you have to deal with
every now and then
are brand new and maybe sometimes
they're things that that you don't have
the right skill sets to do
how do you as the ceo the person that
everybody's looking towards
how do you how do you keep yourself
balanced and making sure that you're
actually doing the right thing
i think the way to do that is learn from
everybody around you
learn from your investors and your board
learn from your executive team
it's interesting as the
founder ceo of a company you get to be
the only executive on the team without
experience and learning right that you
you actually you're right it's an
interesting phenomenon like you
recording scales you end up having very
senior executives around you
which you are much less experienced than
them okay and
and that's okay because you bring
something different to the table
um but you need to be um open and
vulnerable and you need to be able to be
in a position when you're learning
uh from people around you and you're
accepting feedback and so some of the
changes and
evolution uh for me again this is my
first time as a ceo i wasn't a ceo
before
so it is learning through feedback it is
it is being um in a position where you
have your ears open and you're you're
hearing what people are saying and
sometimes
it's painful feedback it's people tell
you you shouldn't be doing this you
should be doing this
um and and you know you could be in a
position and be defensive and
and and clutch on to your previous
behaviors but
then you would not grow so you know i
think part of my ability to grow
as a ceo in this company is just you
know um being open
uh to feedback um reflecting on it and
thinking about
how i can get better every day and that
is something that i do i
i every week i think to myself what
should i be doing and what shouldn't i
be done
i love that y'all thank you so much for
being so generous with your time i know
how busy you are and you have
so much on your plate and i really
appreciate you taking the time to
provide your insights expertise
and and your humble nature honestly it
really does inspire me to to watch a seo
as a learner and and i hope to take a
similar route to yours and and continue
to be
a lifelong learner and keep checking out
who are the right people around me and
what do i need to do to continue
learning and adapting
before we we leave i need three words
that you would use to describe yourself
three words um honest
hard working and funny
try to take things lightly i love that
thank you very very much and uh best of
luck with the blue vine and i hope to
meet in person
after after this whole thing uh spans
out this pandemic thank you
i'm here take care